[Music]
marriage demands that you be the best
version of you where it ain't gonna work
Will Smith gets real about his
relationship with Jada pinkett-smith
amid ongoing divorce rumors at the end
of the day that's a man cat that can
rely on me for the rest of his life
in a new interview on titles rap radar
podcast the 49 year old actor also sets
the record straight and opens up about
redefining his union after more than 20
years of marriage we don't even say
we're married anymore we refer to
ourselves as life partners right where
you get into that space when you realize
you are literally with somebody for the
rest of your life
there's no deal-breakers there's nothing
she could do ever nothing that would
break our relationship she has my
support til death you're not I mean and
it feels so good to get to that space 1
and Jada has shared the same sentiments
as her husband take out all that whole
marriage relationship crap at the end of
the day yeah what will and I our family
I'm going to hold him down it doesn't
matter the girls trip star revealed to
ET a very candid conversation with will
is coming to her read Table Talk series
what in the world are you going to talk
to Wilson will and I actually gonna have
a very interesting conversation about
how our journey in regards to
transforming a marriage into a life
partnership but it's gonna be a really
powerful discussion and how my mother
and how willow and Jaden the whole
family has been involved in this
transformation
[Applause]